Thank you so much.
It's funny that like nobody sat in the
front row but then you guys just became
the front row because your
one back we had isn't it?
I mean, no, I really white weird room.
I feel like I'm a unlike lights.
I wouldn't say cozy,
but I would say thank you so much for
giving up your time and coming to hear us
chatting. We would do well to have
like a little fireplace here or yes,
a comedically oversized
fish tank and maybe drinks.
Yeah, well yeah that happened.
Um, okay. Great. Thanks so
much for joining us today.
Of course your book is amazing. Everybody
should read it. It's fantastic. Yeah.
But I want to talk with you a little bit
about your home life and where you came
from,
I'm sure.
So you've made the rounds from a
comedian to an actress to a writer
and you write a lot. Like if something
doesn't work out then I just,
you write a lot in your book about
your home life and cove and how that's,
so can you tell the audience a little
bit about where you come from and what
your family's like? Yeah. So I'm from
a place in Ireland called cove. I,
is there any other Irish people here
today? Oh you. Oh my God, that's cool.
So you Nicole. So it's like down, uh,
down south and it's um,
it's actually big emigration town,
which I've been thinking about recently
cause it like relates to my work here
because I grew up from where ane where
everybody left from like a million people
left from cove. This is a long time
ago. It's like during the famine,
which is now over.
Obviously we're fine. Um,
I'm actually really full.
Um, but I grew up there.
I'm one of eight children, which is
maybe a little bit more than the norm.
I would say. Like, we still
have big families in Ireland,
but age is the last and very
happy childhood. And uh,
but I do think that's where like my
obsession with immigration started because
we learned about it as
in school all the time,
even to like inappropriate levels where
like I remember learning about like
maritime tragedies of like the
boats leaving cove and crashing.
And then there's the one local
historian came into us and said, um,
the people will be clinging onto the
side of the boats and the other people
we'll be chopping their hands off.
And I was like,
maybe seven and I don't know
that that's ever been verified.
Like anyway, so always in
my mind it was like, oh,
I'm from this place where
people leave from. Um,
and so I write a bit about that
and the raised bed, Annie Moore,
who has been thinking about these
days so much because she's the first
immigrants through the
gates of Ellis Island.
She left from my hometown
of cove in like 1890.
It was like the hundred and 50th
anniversary. I can't really do the,
it was like 18 eight or something.
I think is that right?
150 and I don't know.
Anyway,
it was like 150 years ago and
she was an unaccompanied minor.
She was 17 years old.
She left with her two baby brothers.
So three unaccompanied kids coming across,
no documents, no passport, no visa,
nothing.
And they were welcomed in and they were
reunited with their parents who have
come here years earlier to like make,
you know,
get an apartment and like
start to make a living.
They lived on the lower east
side's for the rest of their lives.
And like I just think how different it
was for them compared to what's happening
to kids today and just all the various,
you know,
issues of race and stuff
around that. Yeah. You also
lived in Zimbabwe as a child.
I did live in Zimbabwe. Yeah.
So Annie Zimbabweans here? No.
What are you nodding your head?
Okay.
Like you're, you are. Oh,
you're like as if there'd
be Zimbabweans here.
Right. True. Very true.
So much easier for white immigrants
from me or I have to get here than it is
from black immigrants from
Zimbabwe. In fact, I, uh, yeah,
I have a friend at the moment who's
trying to get the old one visa,
which is the one I'm on, which is the
alien of extraordinary ability. He,
he's like a one,
this big film festival in Zimbabwe.
Two years ago I was on a hidden camera
show in Ireland. Like, so anyway,
he technically is probably
more extraordinary than I am.
I'm bullish. It's proving a lot
more difficult. And uh, so anyway,
we lived in [inaudible] bad way.
The whole family went and lived there for
two years. My Dad was in construction,
he was building a hotel over there and,
and I think that was a really valuable
experience for me just from,
if any of you have kids.
I don't have any kids, but I know
of, it's like a terrible dope. Um,
she's shaking her head.
You're like a Google executive
would never say it that you,
Kelly and I were talking earlier and
she normally has to interview Google
executive or not Google executives,
executives center lane.
Um, none of who am I hope watch this. No.
But I mean, they're great, but I mean,
they wouldn't make terrible jokes.
They're better. It's better. They wouldn't
be like, oh no, I'm a good speller.
Nor in like that dumb voice.
I think that's lovely.
But anyway, what I was going to
say, it's like if you do have kids,
I really think it's cool too,
like if you can at all.
And it's a hugely privileged thing
to be able to do, to move country,
have them live somewhere else when
they're small so that they can understand
they're not the center of the world's
them and everyone who looks like them.
Because in Ireland everyone is
very, um, I mean like, look,
you can make a few sisters.
And so it's really,
it was a great thing for me to go
away and see like, oh, here's this,
all these other ways of living basically.
Yeah. And you write about growing up in
a family where humor was prized above all
else. Um, so how did that
affect you as a child?
Can you tell the audience
about your family and,
yeah,
I mean I think,
I don't know if it's like a big
family thing if it's an Irish thing,
but certainly being funny
in my family was, you know,
Norman carriage if you're athletic or
clever or being funny was like the thing
that that was, you know, um, and it
wasn't just like Nice, funny, you know,
often there's like an edge to humor and
that's definitely the way my family is
where you kind of sit around the table
and you're going a little bit scared and
then it like starts and um,
it's tough,
but it's like you show your affection
for people by like bullying them.
I grew up in the same kind of family and
I'm curious if that's the experience of
a lot of other Irish
people in the audience.
I mean,
everyone's too nervous to put their
hands up because they've been bullied.
Amazing.
How many are in your family?
Oh, it's small just to, but
I've got loads of cousins,
like, yes. Yeah,
I would definitely kind of cousins and
even our ads and my aunts still gives me
a really hard time and yeah,
it's just never ending.
But I mean I think that's good if you
end up working as the comedian the way I
did,
but also I would say at least two of
my six sisters are funnier than I am.
Like Rosie, my sister who still
lives in [inaudible] four,
we grew up and she's a beautician
and Kohl's and she is like festivals,
who knows all the 10 secrets because
she does all their waxing and you know,
and then and eyebrows and everything.
And then she's really good.
Impressiveness and she's
just like so sharp and funny,
but she doesn't have like a compulsion
to show off about us like some of us do.
When did you realize that being
funny was your superpower? Oh, well,
I'm not being self deprecating when
I say I'm not good at anything else.
Like I'm good at racing and I'm good at
being funny and doing those two things
together.
But I didn't realize the writing
thing until about like five years ago.
Um, and I still need
a lot of outsides. Um,
you know what, like
proof of that. Like, no,
I'm like I write for the New York Times
that has to be mean something, you know,
validation. But with being funny,
I was always like, I'm funny,
even though in school and
everything I was quiet,
but like I was like the kind of
a judgmental outside everyone.
And also I think being female
it's harder to be overtly,
like I'm the funniest one in the
room. You're more sly about us. Um,
so that's, that's kind of what
I always have known. Yeah,
well it's used to great effect. So, um,
thank your writing has been compared
to if David Sedaris and Tina Fey had a
daughter, which I think is, I mean
that's what's on the cover of the book.
You know,
it's not beautiful,
but it's also don't you think it's kind
of grotesque because Tina Fey and David
Sedaris wouldn't have a daughter also.
Like obviously David Sedaris
is a gay man and wouldn't have,
you know,
a change with a straight woman and
she is not that much older than me.
If you could update it to the fan fiction
who you would like to have a daughter?
No, I'd love them to be my parents
or, but I just think in, in,
in the natural order of things,
it would be highly unusual to have a 13
year old mother and a kind of an older
gay man be my be my parents, I guess.
I see where you're coming from.
Do you know what I mean?
But it's, you know,
Glamour magazine said it and then we
were all really happy because it's like
hard to get good quotes. So we
were like, yeah, put it up there.
So who do you look to for
writing inspiration for
writing inspiration? I mean,
I definitely, I tend to read lots
of nonfiction books about war.
Um, so, but for funny writing,
mmm.
I do love David Sedaris,
actually daddy and
um,
uh,
God, well, I'm interested in
hearing about the war bucks as well.
Do they influence? Yeah, I don't know that
they did it. They influence my writing.
I mean,
like I certainly,
I write here about what they went to
Iraq and I did a workshop in Iraq and I
definitely didn't want to be one of those
people who come from the west and like
land there and spend a few weeks
there and you know, go on about like,
oh, the sound of the mosque, you know,
in the early morning or you know,
the usual crap that like,
I feel like white western people right
when they go anywhere there, you know,
or they're like, actually the people
were friendly, you know, this is kind of,
I hate that. Yeah. So maybe it was
helpful to me that I do read it,
you know? Um, there's a really,
I think like my favorite book of the
last year, it's called like, uh, no,
what's it called again?
I told you I'm so doorsy today.
It's a book about Afghanistan and it's
like an American who went to live in
Afghanistan and uh,
and Nan's got pal is the writer's name.
It's called like,
no country for like no good country
for the living or something.
Can you Google it? Can, can you Google it?
It's like everybody makes that joke.
Uh,
no good place for the no good country
for living or something like that.
Sorry. No reception. Um,
anyway, it's a really cool book
because basically he was, he's a,
I think he was like a
neuroscientist, young, you know,
just studying neuroscience.
And then he was downtown when the World
Trade Center attacks happened and he was
like stuck under a car all day.
And like that made him think suddenly
a bit like America's place in the world
and the by geopolitics and
the way that he hadn't before.
And then he just decided to
move to Afghanistan and he
lived there and you know,
and he learned the language and he like
got a motorbike and traveled around and
had access to like even
one member of the Taliban.
And so he just learned so much and then
he wrote about it in a way that was, um,
so informative, but like what really
happened there and what the American,
you know, why it's such a mess. And he
also has these really great human stories.
He traces like three people want to,
Taliban commander,
one is a widow who ended up in
parliament and then he just the,
the combination of, um,
you know, a new story,
deeply researched and like on
the ground and also the human,
um,
both the human costs and human opportunity
because both of those things happen
in war obviously.
Um,
so I loved his rating and I would say
then when I am writing about Iraq or I
also went to Iran,
then I try and think there's
only so much you can,
you know,
be aware of your own biases or whatever.
But I'm always trying to think like,
what if I didn't grow up in Ireland
and didn't live in America? Like,
what would I really be thinking? Or like
what's really happening. That's helpful.
I certainly see a lot of ties
to that in your journalism.
So your podcast and the articles that
you write for the New York Times.
That makes total sense.
Where do you find you're
reading recommendations around
those issues? Um, I mean,
I,
I definitely have a lot of like immigrant
journalists that I follow and that
they're, you know, it's
not hard to find, you know,
it's not hard to find good,
interesting work written by like,
if I'm going to read about
the Mexican American border,
I want to read it from a Mexican
point of view too. Like very simple.
There's very simple ways to,
I think, inform yourself,
unlike,
it is kind of amazing.
It is kind of amazing when you
realize like, oh, the different,
the points of view that I'm getting there.
You know,
you just need to scratch the surface
a bit and look a bit deeper. Um,
I bet a lot of the audience hasn't had
a chance to read the book yet and I'd
love to give them an insight into what
you did in Iraq, if you could tell them.
Oh, sure. So I did a comedy workshop.
I'm talking all about warrants.
What I use it a comedy works off. And, uh,
I went there in 2016 and there
was an herbal, which is, you know,
um, up in Kurdistan and, uh,
it's like a very safe place.
But I did tell my parents
that I was going to Kurdistan,
I didn't specify like Iraq.
And then I,
you know, I got two other comics
to come with me. We're, one is,
he's a TV writer, um, Joe
Randazzo whose name is, and uh,
he used to race for the onion and that,
and then he wrote for at midnight and a
few different and then more Amur who's,
um, uh, techs and comedians
who tour as a Dave Chappelle,
but he's texting by way of like,
his family are Palestinian
and he's Arabic speaking.
So the three of us went it there and
we did a workshop with 40 of our Iraqi
peers and they, um, you know,
I was obviously like a bit hesitant about
like coming from America to like teach,
like the history of American involvement
interact has never been good.
And then also to be like,
hey, we're good. Like,
don't you think jokes are
so important, you know? Um,
and to teach like comedy
or whatever. But, uh,
I did my research. I also like coming
from Ireland as you know, we, you know,
we were a conflict ridden country
for a long time and I was definitely,
I'm definitely too young to
clean that story is my own boss.
Certainly when I used to do gigs
in Belfast, I remember the, um,
owner of the empire,
that comedy club up there,
he said that whenever there
was a very bad atrocity,
that that's Sunday night
for the comedy show.
There will be like lions around the block
and the people really used comedy as a
way to come together and as kind of
a form of relief and an a way to like
connect with each other. And, um,
I always found that really interesting.
Plus like in Northern Ireland,
I think it's fair to say they have like
a slightly darker hue to their humor. Um,
and so going into Iraq,
I kind of thought in my mind too,
they also wanted to talk
about, you know, the, the, um,
power of creativity when you're in,
in,
you know,
going through dark stuff,
whether that's just yourself or it's
your family or it could be your community
or country. Um, but that's all very lofty.
I was really nervous.
And then I got there and of course it was
like doing a comedy workshop anywhere.
Like there was, you know, for
women and 36 men and like,
um, there was, you know, like Goofy,
loud guys who were just wanting to do
comedy to meet women. And then there was,
uh, like older, like earnest
men who kind of were,
had always wanted to express the site
to themselves, but they were, you know,
working or looking after family.
It was just like,
I could have named people's
equivalence like that.
I had met in New Zealand in Edinburgh
and Dublin do not domain. It was cool.
And like,
um,
there was cartoonists there and
people who made short videos and,
um, standup comedy is like
a younger kind of a craft,
uh, in Iraq. And it was a lot of,
there was a sketch group there and
stuff and we just had this workshop.
But it was, it was, it was really
good. Like it was really, um,
helpful I think for, it was
certainly helpful for me. Now.
I hope it was helpful for them too.
And I'm still in touch with a few people.
Took the workshop and what
was extraordinary was no,
we were just like Farsi miles from Mosul,
which was still Andres isis
control at the time. And um,
they making like funny videos about
Isis and like that was kind of the,
you know, isis are still goods
at a social media and that,
that, you know, making videos that travel.
And I think that for the
people at the workshop,
some of whose family they
were IDPs as their family,
we're still stuck on most of the,
um,
I think it was useful for them
to have a comeback and to use to,
you know, use their creativity to
oppose this kind of destruction,
that and this narrative of destruction.
Um,
so that's what they said and I think,
and I do believe them actually,
and I also, I also was like, God, I was
so stupid coming out here thinking, oh,
what's the point of this?
Cause I was like, well, if I,
he just happened to grow up here, I'd be
the one in the workshop. Like, you know,
I'd be one of those kind of like girls
being like, is this going to be good?
You know,
you mentioned the impulse
for self expression.
So if you were a cable of menu would
be the one who is writing on the walls.
Totally.
I'm constantly,
as you could see like trying to
say like trying to figure out what,
what I'm thinking and feeling and how
I understand things and trying to share
that. And it's just a,
I think it's very human.
Maybe it's like a bit stronger
in some of us than others,
but I think it's a very
human impulse to try and say,
like to just express yourself
and then to get heard is amazing.
Yeah. Well we all reap the benefits
of you expressing yourself.
So thank you for that outcome.
The teaching,
this comedy workshop opened up a lot of
questions about the shared space between
comedy and tragedy.
And I'm going to read a little excerpt
of a question that you pose, which is,
Oh God,
if comedy and creativity,
these nebulous things I've
devoted all these years too,
are in fact in the grand scheme of
things unhelpful or even pointless.
So how did your experience help to clarify
those questions and do you still have
our struggle with them?
Um, I think, you know,
a lot of times comedy,
like I think that we pat ourselves on the
back too much. Like, I think, you know,
if you're on the kind
of left side of things,
you like watch John Oliver
and you're like, yeah,
like get him like you said it
or Jon Stewart or whatever.
And ultimately I don't think it's really,
I don't think if your goal is to change
things, I don't think that's changing.
It's like you get a laugh
and you feel good, but,
and you'd definitely get that sense
like we're a tribe, but like that's,
I don't know how helpful that is. Um, so,
but for when I went and
spent that time in Iraq,
I do think that I could see the
value of it from a kind of a,
just to,
it's an part of being human.
And I think often when people
are serious all the time,
even if it's because they're sad or
because something bad is happening,
I think that's a disservice
to their own like humanity.
Because I think in all of us there's like
light and dark and there's levity and
there's depth and like,
unless you allow both of them to come out,
then it's like you're not being fair.
It's like if you were like giddy and uh,
upbeat all the time,
that's not a true representation of what,
you know,
really being a human. Yeah. So
that's why I think, you know,
a lot of narratives around,
you know,
of course like around war and
of course around immigration,
like forced immigration,
like what's happening to Syrians
are so tragic and so sad.
But within those stories,
which I found in my podcast when I
interviewed Syrian asylum seekers,
like there's, there's jokes,
there's love, there's humor,
you know,
there's all those things that like
people who aren't in a war and people who
don't, um, feel a great sadness,
like they still get to have, they
still get to have that levity. Yeah.
But I think it gets lost
in the telling sometimes.
What made you choose to do a podcast on
immigration? What I think it was, because,
you know, like I was saying,
where I came from was, you know,
I'd under such a country
that just pushes people.
I always all the time and we ended up
all over the world and then I became an
immigrant myself,
like moved here five years ago.
And I could definitely see the contrast
between my immigration experience and so
many other people's. And it was definitely
a question of like, hmm, like why me?
And like why not them and why not, you
know, because America is such a fortress.
Really. Um, so and also so there was that,
there was just that central question
of like, what's really going on here,
but also immigration stories as you know,
if you're an immigrant yourself
or if you're knowing immigrants,
like there's always a
story there because it,
it literally means you've left one life
behind and you've come and stash it a
new life. And that is like from
a storytelling point of view,
there's has to be something there. Even
like the most boring immigration story.
There's a story,
there's a,
there's the beginning of the middle
and then what's happened now. Yeah,
the podcast is no longer in production,
but the back issues are amazing.
And if you haven't listened
to it, you really should.
It hits all the right notes.
Oh, thanks. To change hearts and
minds. Yeah, absolutely. Well,
I mean you say that it
changed hearts and minds,
but like it's interesting cause I
really thought like, so basically the,
the podcast is quite simple.
It's like me interviewing different
immigrants about their own stories.
It was like immigration stories told
by the people who've lived them.
And I really thought like, you know,
we went into production and you know,
2015 when I started the
idea working on too.
That's 15 that, but the way the
timing worked, well, you know,
the show only started airing like
right after Trump got elected.
And then I think he was inaugurated while
I was still taping and the west coast
anyway. And so obviously the, you know,
the immigration is always a
huge topic here in America,
but it had really heated up.
Um,
and I think I did naively probably think,
oh, but if anybody hears this,
like if they hear, you know,
as Azad, the Syrian asylum
seeker, if they talk,
if they hear him talking
about like how he read,
he needs to quit smoking because he has
this one year old now and his wife is
giving him a hard time and yeah,
he wants to quit smoking,
but he's afraid he's gonna put weights
on cause he's like a comfort Eser,
you know, like he, he reminded me of my
uncle and I was like, when they hear him,
they're not going to be
scared of Syrians and like,
they're not going to even consider
a Muslim ban or whatever Bush,
you know,
I don't know that a hearing stories
from immigrants directly does
change hearts and minds. I like to hope
that it does. I hope that it does too,
but I, I, it's hard to get that
qualitative, like does it actually, yeah.
I don't know. I, it's a really, I'm
still trying to figure out, yeah,
I think reaching the correct audience is
probably the hardest part of the battle.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Um, so
there's an innate tension, um,
in the whole book about the hope you
have for humanity, a society and, um,
the insecurity of the self that
everybody faces. Um, so can you, uh,
give us any words of wisdom for people
in the audience who might want to make a
difference in the world
and contribute to change,
but I need the courage to start.
Well,
I mean,
I could say what I am
doing like at the moment,
which is like kind of a small thing,
but it's actually like having me.
But so like,
um,
I started this other podcast this
year and it's about a climate justice,
which is something I never I knew about,
but I wasn't really like
paying attention anyway. I, uh,
we did this issue, we did this episode
about divestments, you know, like big,
big countries or corporations
or universities or whatever
divesting their money
from,
say like fossil fuels,
funding of fossil fuel operations to
putting it into something else like clean
energy or something that's kind of a,
you know,
whatever cleaner and better for the
environment and on better from a human
rights point of view.
And stuff.
And so then we did this whole episode
and I was kind of like, okay, cool.
Like you can petition your,
your government to divest which interests.
The great news is I at the
Irish government has recently
divested all of their
money, which is amazing. Um,
but then I was looked at chase bank,
which is just like where I bank for no
reason except that that's where I opened
up the bank account. And um,
and then I was like, well,
I'm going to move my money at the,
this is like last week I was
on the phone to them and it,
I owed them four grand.
Like I had like zero on my current
count and minus a minus four grand in my
credit card. So I was like
taking a high morals to, I was,
I phoned them and I was like,
I think I'm gonna leave the bank because
I've been reading all this stuff and
like you use, you've been funding this
huge tar sands project and you know,
and the lady was like,
you can't leave like you owe us.
And I was like, no, I know. But
you know, I'm telling you like, um,
anyway then cause the day your
book gets published, published,
you get your check or whatever. So I got
my check on Tuesday was a sure. Yeah.
And then I was like, you
know, duty or Roberts kind of,
you know that moment where she goes
back into the shop and she's like,
big mistake,
but still the woman and chase
is like, fine, you can leave.
Like they were just like, what
is your problem? Anyway, so, uh,
and then like this other lady, cause
I was like, I should record this.
Like it's really funny.
And this other lady,
first of all I call chase and I was like,
now I have money and I'm paying off my
credit card and you're not getting the
rest of my money or whatever.
And then it's like a lady who works
in a call center in the Philippines,
you know, and I wasn't about to
like go off on her, you know,
do you know what you're doing?
Like climate change is real problem.
She's in Philippines. Like
I think she knows. And, uh,
we had a really nice chat
actually and she was like, look,
I'm going to do my homework
after this. And it was like, Hey,
sorry to keep you on the phone.
And um,
then I got put through to media relations
cause I was requiring or whatever and
she hung up on me, this lady and like
the Manhattan branch hung up on me.
So anyway, this is, I'm sorry,
this is really long winded way of saying
I'm personally taking responsibility
for like, this is like the best small
thing right? Where my money goes.
I also, um, you know, when
it comes to immigration,
I try and really look at my own status,
which like I said is I
have this o one visa,
which is a very privileged one to get.
And I try and help other people get
it and I just try and speak to and
understand other points of view.
It's very basic.
Like that's like I said,
when I started the podcast I was like
my responsibility as a storyteller.
It's changed the ash shoot
towards immigration in this
country. And it's like, no,
I can to that.
Like,
what I can do personally really do
is like these small things. I can,
you know,
another thing which is more again,
climate justice related is like
check where my food comes from.
That's just like order
seamless all the time. Yeah.
Which is like a lot of packaging
and a lot of, you know, very.
So I'm doing very small things.
Yeah. That's like my latest approach.
Yes.
I'm hearing start small and speak to your
talents because you've leveraged your
talents and incredible
ways to effect change. Um,
I want to leave space for
audience questions. Please
don't be shy. If you want to,
uh, ask them thing and we've
got microphones and you
could ask me for a loan.
That was a good time.
Um,
but also, um, this book was a completed
about a year ago. Is that right?
Yeah.
I basically finished it last September
and that it's quite a long process with
publishing there. Takes away what's
changed in your life since then.
And I got a dog,
I got a dog.
I,
God made a columnist at the times and at
the garden and also at the progressive,
another magazine. So suddenly now we
have a lot of writing work to do, um,
which is fine.
Um,
and I think that's kind of it.
Yeah,
that's big.
You have a really cute passage about
so many cute passages about dogs. Fuck,
what do you see?
Cause I
always walk, um, dogs from
Shawn Casey. It's like Eh,
rescue place and you can walk dogs
from there. Like you don't have to,
I mean really, you just go in
and give your email address.
I think they kind of want
you just to take them. Um,
and then you can take the
dog to the park or whatever.
And I used to always do that and I was
like, I kind of get a dog, you know,
like with money and like looking
at the time and everything,
but then I just kind of go, you
know, I don't know if you have a dog,
but like what happens is you
act like you're just going
to foster it for a while.
Anyway, I ended up getting this
dog full time now for almost
and uh, and it's great. Like, actually
when I got her, I was like, she's,
I guess she's like half border collie.
So I was like,
she's going to be real busy and energetic
and she's gonna make me start running.
I said, I used to run, I don't run
anymore. And then, um, I was like,
it's going to be so good for me and
my mental health and I go to like lose
weight and everything. She's also half
period anyway. She's like the laziest,
not lazy, but like she's a puppy
and she's just like, let's news.
So she, yeah. So that's what's happened to
me for a puppy. She's a big puppy. Yeah.
She's 60 pounds now cause she just
sleeps all the time. I'll do it. Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
so we covered your,
a trip to Iraq and mentoring Iraqi
comics and all the issues that come up.
My Dog, oh, we hit all the big ones
around the Berlin utility of comedy
and its relationship to tragedy.
There's this really
interesting juxtaposition in
the book about your hope for
all of these comics and how they can
affect change and um, being very, uh,
positive and optimistic about the
role of comedy in politics in Iraq,
but 80 saw a lot of, um,
insecurity bubbling up around
the podcast and it's, uh,
it's ability to affect
change in the same way.
I'm an imposter syndrome is something
that we talk about a lot at Google.
It's a big discussion point.
Um,
so do you have any words of wisdom about
kind of closing that gap between how
you perceive other people and how you
can bring your own self perception to the
same place?
Yeah,
I mean I this,
this newest product podcasts and I'm
working on is with Mary Robinson,
who's the former president of Ireland.
She's a first female president
and she's 73 years old now.
And so you can imagine what it was like
for her coming off as if she was a human
rights lawyer first. And
like this thick, I guess the,
I guess the 70s in Ireland,
which was a tough time for like women
and she was like human rights lawyers.
So anyway, I asked her about
that cause I think it's like a
real phenomenon with younger women.
Maybe men feel it to imposter syndrome.
I hear most from women,
but maybe men feeder too.
Um,
and I asked her about it and she was like,
I never had us,
she was so unhelpful.
Like I really thought that she should
have some kind of like w why is,
and she was just like,
no, I don't know. Um,
and someone else did,
I talked to about this,
she's a black woman and she was like,
I don't have time for like, she's like,
everyone does doubt me.
Everyone in her,
I guess she's means not,
not black people,
does doubt her and she does have
to prove yourself all of the time.
So if she also dives herself.
So that made me think this is just one
black woman. I don't know if that's,
you know, but that made me think like,
hmm. Like, I wonder if it's a bit of a
making a problem where there isn't one.
Um,
but I feel it, it's a real, you know,
and I know like feelings aren't facts,
but whatever. I do still feel it
a bit myself and I feel like what,
you know what too,
I think I'm doing here or if I'm doing
like a high status thing or whatever,
I'm like,
um,
I think it's helpful to,
uh,
remind yourself of past
like using logic helps me,
like I can say to myself,
but you did this other thing like two
weeks ago and that was on the same level
and you did fine. So like
using, using logic to say like,
I wasn't cut out then nobody kicked me
out then. So like I can do this again.
And then I used that for a lot of things
to trick my brain. Like I often think,
oh, I'm not going to be
able to write this piece.
Like it's too hard or it's too
long or it's whatever I don't sign.
But then I think, but you thought
that before, but you did it.
So just using evidence from your past as
amazing and a very data based company,
it should resonate for
us. Yeah. Yeah. Alright.
Well thank you so much for joining.
I said Google today.
I'm may even America essays
by a girlfriend somewhere
else's now available. Uh,
pick it up on Google play or we
have copies in the back. Hopefully.
Maybe we'll rallies signed some
copies as well. Sure. Yeah. Um,
but thank you so much for joining us.
It was a pleasure. Thank you Kelly. Um,
yeah, you ask such good questions. Thank
you. Yeah. Like you really read the book.
I was doing radio interviews this
week. You wouldn't, you don't know.
I was doing radio as a sneak
it radio interviews and
some people were like, yeah,
oh moles. Oh, great to Tom and
just send it for the compliments.
Um,
does anybody have any questions?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Yep.
No, but you're, there are other spellings,
more complicated ways to spell my name,
but luckily this was the, the ones my
parents gave me. I know another may have,
she's like m a e d h be hates.
And people are just like,
ah, the head that had passed.
So I, this is like co kind
of finessed sec, you know,
like people definitely call me met
eve, but I answer to, that's fine.
Like mobe is my worst because
I don't like that color. Huh.
I'm just like, what?
But I do answer to move.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
Are you able to,
are you still know what stand up and let's
say Improv even cause underwriting or
you could you see yourself going
back to that at some stage?
Um,
I mean I still do bits of stands up.
Like definitely racing is 80% or 90%
probably know of my time and stuff.
But I do a show every Monday in Brooklyn
with my friends or parent and nine
Sharla and Joel fires don't too.
Very good comics.
And we do a show there every month is
that kind of keeps my hand in and I see
all the youngsters coming up.
Um, but I don't, but yeah,
it is mainly racing.
No worries. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
You've lovely accent
park. Is that, where are
you from? Dublin. Tony Gone.
We've a good spread of Irish
people here. Yeah. All right.
Thank you so much everybody.
Thanks everyone.